last night was the people's State of the
Union
it's the left-wing tofu to tonight's
State of the Union you want a taste
have a bucket nearby this man named
Ziggy who claims to be Teddy got rid of
climate science programs already he
actually rides his horse to work like up
that's Fisher Stevens I thought he was
dead but he's still alive and apparently
a celebrity afterwards
news outlets focused on one thing only
star power not the principal's star
power because without that the event was
just a rehash of anti West hard left
diatribes American caused genocide check
evil white male privilege check real
winners there but what caught the press
was not the radicalism but that it was
star studded true there was Mark Ruffalo
and Kathy Najimy if that star studded so
is any rest stop on Sunset Boulevard I
should know what the press ignored the
same divisive politics that spooks most
Americans blaming others for your
problems is so last decade and yet they
they can't stop but what's also weird
this event was last night before the
actual speech which tells you everything
they only want to hear themselves but
the curse of refusing to hear those who
disagree with you remove the one step
that unites people which is conversation
which leads only then to conflict
without it but maybe that's what they
want the people say that the union may
not be about people at all but division
and emotional actors whose celebrity
provides cover for their unpopular
radical beliefs and they need to cover
because no one wants leftism it hurts
too many lives look at history so last
night may have felt like a great movie
for the media but it's one movie that
America will happily skip you know Jesse
what drove me nuts about this and I say
driving me nuts loosely because I really
don't care that's already that's already
everything was about how star-studded it
was they totally left out the fact that
what they were
talking about was so purely
anti-american drivel that you've heard
for 4050 years but that just you know
got some calmness for people they can't
handle that here's how I knew it wasn't
star-studded when one yesterday asked
who was going to be at the event and we
said Mark Ruffalo and he said who's that
and then he said well what movies he'd
be in and we all started googling Mark
Ruffalo yeah
these guys aren't a listers and they
tried the all they care about is who
they are not what they say because if
you put them in a panel I'm up here like
this
they can't debate the issues that's true
there's no substance the argument it's
all anger and something Mark Ruffalo
said that really kind of bothered me he
accused President Trump of being lazy
yeah Buffalo wakes up and does 10 a.m.
yoga on a beach in Malibu and then goes
gets his fingernails waxed this guy is
not a hard worker being an actor and
Holly was the easiest job in the world
don't tell someone else you don't have a
good working you gotta try it too many
and he means fingernail buffing but he
also lives in New York one michael moore
used the phrase cleanse when he was
talking about white males like we need
to cleanse white male privilege do you
think it's gonna go over well with
middle america yeah
let's cleanse america of white male
privilege which basically says like get
rid of white males no it's not it's my
privilege but by the way i mean if you
talk about low-wattage celebrities i
mean you know is this essentially is a
left-wing version of the tea party back
in 2010 tea party was actually americans
go tell me this what celebrity quotient
of the tea party that's what i said they
didn't have any so that's what just very
gently very apple or either one or
seamlessly try party was an actual
organic real movement americans this is
not real let me tell you this is so real
they head town hall in the middle of
Manhattan packed last Manhattan
it's celebrity workout for Hillary they
put her over the top let me just say
they had hundreds of thousands of people
watching streaming including wise God
fell I watched my god I don't know how
they got a happen I watched it was also
sort of your assignment but you had to
go monologue on its own Greg's behalf
let me drop the bomb for you guys the
Blasio was there go ahead guys blow up
blow up I know you don't like the Blasio
surprising that de Blasio it really do
you care that the plaza was there like
who I like to call lurch I mean if Big
Bird was there that just he's definitely
not an event you wanted to via what can
I tell you I mean look I don't care if
they have beer seedless I'd rather have
the real people that you have new Tea
Party movement than like celebrities
without scripts not a good idea
trying to come forward to proffer some
enthusiasm and sense of honor and
integrity to try to criticize what's
happening in this country I don't think
it worked it didn't do anything for me
it didn't move me didn't move my diet
used a Clooney than Diddy and now they
have de Blasio I think that says it all
I mean I will say this day night I
watched it and I saw like Ruffalo really
believes it and he has the energy I
could see him possibly running because
he's not really a big star very into the
environment and he said yeah oh he was
bragging about not bragging but talking
about the whole pipeline protests how
that end up right yeah getting approved
mark so the Democrats are in a real
pickle people watch your mouth they have
this division and it's hard how do you
figure it out if you're Chuck Schumer
when you're trying to figure it out
their goal in 2018 is to try to take
back the Senate right and the house but
the Senate in particular and he's got
red state Democrats that are having to
run for reelection in ten states where
President Trump won some of those states
by double digits right and yet he has a
base that is pulling them so far to the
left and they are energized young people
aren't energized by this type of
Hollywood thing and they don't read
history but they don't they don't know
about communism and socialism and how
many millions have died by these what a
challenge
to a debate yes the celebrities
versafine yes family feud Mark Ruffalo
Fisher Stevens and his crazy beard who
else was there
Kathy Najimy I think that was going if
he brings the harmonica yes you forgot
my favorite Cynthia Nixon [ __ ] and she
made a great point which is that a year
ago when Trump gave his speech guess
what Russia was hanging over Trump's
head and tonight as he gives the speech
Russia is still hanging over Trump's
head that's interesting that none of
those liberals in the 70s or 60s Russia
wasn't never hanging over their heads
they were fellow travelers Russia didn't
help them get elected the Moscow Nixon
say she might run first I don't know
she'd better not run until she does the
sex in the sequel sex of the city sequel
because that's more important section to
sequel sex to the sequel
that's very strange